welcome to this video playing is a call
again like him what did I play other
blumenfeld game just recently was this
blumenfeld let's just switch to
something entirely different then the
Chavin ankles love mixing it with with
36 okay the quest one question I'm
asking my service this is a setup that
Iranian often places hard I'm always
asking myself isn't c5 possible here I
know a 6 yeah c65 losing some moves but
this age 3 III b3 is not especially um
great as well hmm interesting so hanging
pawns
mmm interesting way to play don't really
know how i should shower should continue
now the light squared Bishop is a
problem and b6 would be probably quite
okay if I hadn't played a six but this
particular position b6 looks really
weakening hmm but how do I develop now I
don't know how okay let's do that it's
it's maybe bad i don't know but i don't
see a good development plan otherwise
bishop e6 was the only other way but I'm
not convinced I came at least there was
no immediate refutation I mean he didn't
play one I mean maybe there was one but
he didn't come up with something super
convincing he's 62 stabilized yeah maybe
c5 I can take BCD CD for this isn't the
problem yeah this this move I thought
about earlier but I thought I can just
take it and claim that this is misplaced
with moves like be five even but they
see this night c5 hmm
I'm hoping that this is enough concrete
counter play my ideas okay after this I
want to play b5 clearing clearing this
the situation yeah this was the point
that I'm able to capture and now take
him so that at the end I have this this
nice square on d5 this one on yeah
probably this one mm okay I need to get
rid of this pin hard to play against it
q5 you probably I need to annually need
to break the pin i cannot i cannot make
this work without the moose ok and now
unfortunately rook p8 is not on because
of the special on g3
and now he's got to Queenie 423 and this
is stupid yeah this was really really
stupid chest what the heck yeah well I
need to retreat now or this one ah what
a how long yeah yeah just very bad okay
so let's see one minute 30 even behind
on the clock
and I keep overlooking moves
yeah I taking you on as the earth I
think he can take on f6 simply didn't do
that it was probably winning maybe it's
not necessary it's that's possible Queen
p5 I can actually do this
yeah he's just threatening to take and
queen age seven a half no defense
against it understand i def six month
for sign warning so idiotic last just
resign completely idiotic chess i mean
this this should be okay for black I
mean not nothing too too exciting but it
should be okay and I'm just I'm just
killing myself here in five movers or so
just just completely ah even g5 I mean
okay I probably right that the spin is
an annoying annoyance but I just hear
whatever but the real the real idiocy is
this this is just yeah you need to just
dis lose this but this is also just
terrible just losing two moves and then
he's got everything right yeah just just
bad just bad play and eat oh I need to
avoid maybe even h6 and g5 the problem
is this is bishop on g3 is also covering
be eight so this is an additional issue
maybe this this one on another attacking
here yeah something like that just not
g5 and this is this bloody night move
walking right into queen d three this is
so easy alright thanks for watching